yes Dad I know but the mortgage rates
are crazy right now and the shampoo I
use for my luscious new locks has gone
up a whole dollar
what do you mean who cares uh I gotta go
what was that about I was just on the
phone with my dad trying to find some
economic sympathy he said well back in
my day I had to pay 8 000 on my mortgage
doesn't he see that lots of terrible
things are happening well he lived
through a pretty tough economy between
the 70s and 80s High inflation supply
chain issues tension with the Soviet
Union shocking gas prices and ballooning
interest rates which would eventually
lead to the worst downturn since the
Great Depression so I am right we should
be freaking out hold on there Henny
Penny the sky is not necessarily falling
there's a lot that's different but to be
fair getting out an umbrella might not
be the worst idea
[Music]
thank you
it's 1965 London England the right
honorable gentleman Ian Norman MacLeod
is giving a speech to the House of
Commons in it he would introduce what
would become famous economic portmanteau
amen we now have the worst of Both
Worlds not just inflation on the one
side or stagnation on the other but both
of them together we have a sort of
stagflation situation in history in
modern terms is indeed being made
stagflation as it came to be known is
when an economy experiences a nasty
blend of two things inflation the
overall raising of prices and economic
stagnation usually indicated by high
unemployment rate and decreased economic
growth now at the time this combo was
considered to be an economic Yeti
prevailing economic theory at the time
was dominated by the work of John
Maynard Keynes after watching the
devastation caused by the Great
Depression he argued that governments
needed to get more involved during
economic downturns in order to
effectively cushion the blow for its
citizens this would in turn help
stimulate the economy back to health
keynesians generally saw inflation as a
result of economic growth and believed
it to be directly correlated to lower
unemployment there's even a fancy graph
to show this called the Phillips curve a
fabulous name if I may say so myself
however the events of the mid 70s would
seemingly break this somewhat reassuring
pattern many are worried that economic
indicators in this post-covered shocked
world are neatly aligned for a similar
meltdown that we saw in the early 80s a
time before most of the people watching
this video were even born it's true that
there are a good amount of similarities
in October of 1973 war broke out between
Israel and a group of Arab countries the
U.S and the Soviet Union try tried to
bolster their respective allies which
led to a rather terrifying buildup of
tensions between two nuclear Powers
sound familiar
in response to the US's support of the
Israelis the organization of Arab
petroleum exporting countries proclaimed
an oil embargo within three months the
price of oil nearly quadrupled however
kovid and the resulting energy hikes hit
a really strong and growing economy this
wasn't the case in the 70s the oil
crisis poured salt on an already
bleeding wound of a bear Market in 1971
president Richard Nixon clumsily broke
away from the Bretton Woods agreement
and international monetary system put in
place in the summer of 1944 and the
dollar tanked the toxic mix of events
would cause the market to lose around 48
percent of its value it would take
another 21 months to recover this became
known as the Nixon shock today the war
in Ukraine is creating a similar effect
of nudging elevated post-covet Energy
prices even higher with European nations
really bearing the brunt of the hit
these energy she costs shocks are also
coming on the heels of historically low
interest rates and Rising debt loads the
same was true in the 70s however it's
important to point out that the
magnitude of the price shocks at least
as of now have not been nearly as
drastic things did improve following the
crash of 1973 as they did post 2020 but
not for that long the Iranian Revolution
kick-started another oil crisis in 1979
more than doubling the price in one year
unemployment was also on the rise and
inflation was hovering around seven
percent by this point people were tired
and the economic ground was ripe for a
new approach enter Paul volcker as the
chairman of the Fed volcker was pretty
convinced the issue of inflation had
been caused by the government pumping
money into the system by raising rates
and making money more expensive to
borrow he hoped demand would fall and
ease pressure on Supply hopefully
resulting in stabilization and
eventually reduction of prices so down
came the interest rate Hammer by 1981
the average rate on a 30-year mortgage
was an eye-watering
18.45 percent yikes and no wonder I
couldn't get sympathy from my dad in
some ways it did the trick inflation
plummeted by the end of 1982 but that
Victory came at a huge cost unemployment
at the time hit an overall peak of 10.8
percent but 90 percent of the unemployed
were in Blue Collar Goods production
like manufacturing and construction this
left a lasting impact on large swaths of
the country now known as the Rust Belt
that heavily relied on these industries
entire communities were routed and many
have never recovered there's still a lot
of debate as to whether the Cure was
worse than the disease now it seems the
FED has decided to take a somewhat
similar approach and is raising rates
their whole hope is that they can
effectively walk an economic tightrope
raising raids while keeping unemployment
in check thankfully inflation has
started to drift downward since its peak
of around nine percent this past summer
and while that sounds good it's not all
rainbows and unicorns think about what
this represents in real life terms many
people who had dreams of finally taking
their hard-earned savings to buy a home
or start a business or grow their family
are deciding that the cost just isn't
worth it individuals and communities
feel this in a way that can't be
captured in some economic chart so is a
terrible recession on the way or not no
one really knows it is true that many of
the ingredients going into this economic
recipe look the same but the oven
they're getting cooked in is very
different in general our global economy
is far more flexible than it was back
then most central banks have mandates
for things like price stability and
inflationary targets and I pay super
close attention to this stuff even
though kovid was a shock the inflation
that came after really wasn't unlike in
the 70s we actually had historic
precedent for this and most governments
were somewhat prepared it also helps
that unemployment is currently really
low in fact as of filming it's only 0.2
percent higher than it was in February
of 2020. however we are in the midst of
a big economic transition covid made the
economy sick so we pumped it with meds
that caused other problems that we're
now dealing with as we globally continue
to heal the best thing you can do to
prepare for times like this is to make
sure you've got a proper emergency fund
and that your Investments are
Diversified there's a reason that
professionals like us sound like a
broken record about this during the good
times the deeper and wider your
financial Roots the less likely you are
to fall when the wind inevitably changes
Direction
and that's our two cents
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
Patron
want to learn more about pandemic
inflation check out our episode why are
prices going up
[Music]